we both know what it means but does it
have the same resonance have you ever
known its absence have you watched it
disappear Benet
1972 Liberia
1980 Ghana
1981 oh yes it can vanish in a gunshot
or a radio in
[Music]
opens with fellow countrymen and just
like that dust clouds obscure the colors
of daily life khy green and black
leather unsettle the streets trees
branches choots and Roots surrender to
the Furious wind blowing through the
Sahel it always starts with one man and
his gun pedling Promises of new
beginnings I have come to save you he
says his finger dancing on a trigger
save yourself Soldier we've been here
before we know what happens when the
Euphoria settles into a cycle of Terror
and
fear soon the Jack Boots take over the
markets left right right left right
wrong fire strong arm of justice is
fractured it's house arrest for the
gavel and the hand that wields it wigged
Warriors become acquainted with a jingle
of a wers key decrees overturn laws
impunity Trump's
freedoms we've seen it all
before
Sierra Leon
1992 Nigeria
1993 Togo 2005 Mali
2020 Chad
[Music]
[Applause]
2021 we know how this goes Freedom
Fighters flee in the dead of the night
men and women are lost forever shot
poisoned blown up by letter bomb memory
is tied to a stake history silenced by
firing squad the sword decapitates the
pen spilling blood on every page words
are no longer enough to keep the wise
alive
live we've heard it all before
transition and return to civilian rule
in 3 months 6 months 2 years 10 years a
fragile state is caught in the
crosshairs of a power struggle between
those who fight with their blood and
those who seize it for themselves power
cleanses all
Guinea
2021 Sudan
2021 Bina Faso
2022 nir
[Music]
2023 you talk about its erosion the
distress the decadence the disruption of
Institutions you mouth the words on TV
in small small and capital letters say
something about State capture sit tight
presidents and strong men but no one
mentions the sit tight imperialists who
forget that we were here before they
washed up on our Shores Bibles in hand
eyes on our gold diamonds and uranium
colonialists cists who can tell one from
the other in these Seas of crime and
[Music]
corruption some of us have walked this
road before we remember the Wailing of
the dispossessed the
disenfranchised the Disappeared we know
what it means when there is no escape
from the heat of tyranny and every
Victory is snatched from death's
yawn this is why
we fight to keep it fold it into our
palms hold it
tight this is why we must hammer out its
imperfections pound it mold it bake it
in the kils of our
histories we chant because we remember
and we never want to live a day without
it ever again
[Music]